buon pomeriggio
non so se qualcuno di voi ha avuto modo
di seguire la polemica che c'è stata e
che tuttora in corso in questi giorni
sulle ng che fanno salvataggio ricerca e
salvataggio nel mediterraneo
ecco per quelli a cui fosse sfuggito
qualche elemento di questa cosa ricordo
il procuratore della repubblica di
catania zucchero ha aperto un'indagine
sulle ing perché si dice circola voce
qualcuno sostiene che alcune ng di
quelle che con le barche nel
mediterraneo recuperano le vittime dei
naufragi e i trafficanti che trasportano
quelle vittime più che altro si tratta
di deduzioni che derivano dal fatto che
secondo alcuni ci sarebbe una comunione
di interesse i trafficanti vogliono
portare i rifugiati in europa leo ng
vogliono salvare le vittime dei naufragi
queste due cose si combinano e in
qualche modo perché no potrebbe esserci
un accordo zucchero
lo dice non ho nessuna prova anche gli
indizi sono piuttosto deboli sì c'è una
telefonata un po ambigua sono cose che
circolano però visto il successo di
queste sue prime sia pure debolissime e
direi dal punto di vista giuridico
discutibilissime affermazioni pubbliche
il successo che è stato marcato
soprattutto dal fatto che alcuni
personaggi politici hanno ripreso queste
dichiarazioni per farne e in qualche
modo un elemento di polemica politica in
particolare l'onorevole di maio l'amico
dei congiuntivi che forse avete
identificato
il procuratore zucchero ha detto tra
l'altro ritengo che ci sia dietro una
motivazione è una finalità molto più
grave che è quella di destabilizzare
l'economia italiana
portiamo i rifugiati in italia per
destabilizzare l'economia italiana
se avessi saputo che così facili per
stabilizzare l'economia della settima
potenza economica mondiale mi sarei
forse fatto altri programmi nella vita
avrei guardato ad altri problemi ma
lungi da me quello di voler come dire
sottovalutare la potenza delle
organizzazioni non governative delle
organizzazioni della società civile
ho i miei dubbi soprattutto sulla
capacità di analisi economica del
procuratore zucchero comunque tant'è la
polemiche sul tavolo è stata ripresa
ampiamente giornalistici sono saltati
sopra diverse testate per rimarcare
quella che appare sempre più come una
divisione molto chiara nella nostra
società che sta emergendo con grande
forza negli ultimi anni che quella tra
chi mi riconosco in questo gruppo crede
nei valori della consistenza nel diritto
internazionale nella solidarietà nel
fatto che tutti gli esseri umani hanno
gli stessi diritti e che questi debbano
essere protetti per tutti quanti da chi
crede nel buon governo da chi crede
nella necessità di una politica che
abbia al centro l'uomo e chi invece
predica divisione predica separazione
parla di noi contro di loro
chi vuole emarginare chi vuole
condannare interi gruppi etnici o
religiosi o culturali o anche politici
perché no in indifferentemente di
rispetto a quello che fanno che
rappresentano ma perché in questa
divisione prosperano alcune fortune
politiche
prendo voti perché parla alla pancia
della parte peggiore
di quelli che credono a tutto di quelli
che credono le scie chimiche di quelli
che credono che i vaccini portino la
morte di quelli che credono che bisogna
mantenerli a casa loro non devono venire
qui nel nostro mondo intatto a dire
questo normalmente sono persone che
vestono jeans levi's indossano
berrettini da baseball e felpe con
magari di un'università americana che
però vogliono tutelare la propria
identità magari padana sono le
contraddizioni che dobbiamo fare ci
dobbiamo convivere però non c'è dubbio
che tutto questo sta generando delle
dinamiche estremamente preoccupanti nel
mondo
scusate cerco di identificare il tasto
giusto se il mondo sta cambiando e vero
non sta cambiando in meglio mi permetto
di dire emergono personaggi che
praticano la violenza
l'arroganza del potere che vogliono la
divisione che vogliono emarginare che
vogliono condannare interi gruppi etnici
che vogliono costruire i muri alle
frontiere dell'europa li stanno
costruendo anzi e stanno ricreando
un'europa divisa stanno ricreando un
europa dove i diritti umani non sono più
centrali nel discorso europeo ma dove
diventano una merce che bisogna in
qualche modo cercare di contenere di
ridurre in parte di cancellare con le
politiche anti terrorismo con le
politiche dell'immigrazione con le
politiche di emarginazione alcuni di
questi personaggi parlano contro gli
omosessuali parlano contro le donne
parlano contro i disabili contro tutti
quelli che sono in qualche modo
portatori di una diversità rispetto a un
modello teorico che francamente mi
sfugge non riesco ad identificare ma che
loro probabilmente erano molto
chiaramente in testa non va bene tutto
questo sta creando delle divisioni molto
forti nella società in cui quelli che io
considero i portatori dei valori giusti
di un'etica giusta di un'etica più umana
di un
etica di eguaglianza tra gli esseri
umani di un'etica di dialogo di apertura
di tolleranza stanno in una posizione
decisamente subalterna stanno perdendo
nel dibattito politico anche da noi
prosperano i seminatori di odio di
divisione di discriminazione le
rappresento solamente due perché sono
quelli più palesi ma sappiamo che ormai
sono sempre più numerosi politici che
aderiscono in qualche modo a questi
manifesti e lo stato sta in qualche modo
a guardare direi il nostro ministro
dell'interno che mezzo cattivista dice
beh sì non bisogna generalizzare
parlando delle energie dei loro contatti
con i trafficanti non bisogna
generalizzare
però è indubbio che qualcosa ci deve
essere
se c'è la possibilità del peccato
sicuramente ci sarà il peccatore e
quindi si alimenta anche lo stato non fa
più da muro lo stato non è più quello
che in qualche modo asserisce i valori
centrali della giustizia e dell'equità
dell'eguaglianza dei diritti lo stato si
fa ammiccante complice la paura di
perdere voti per i politici è talmente
forte che alla fine se si tratta di fare
la faccia brutta facciamo pure la faccia
brutta
raramente un politico decide di
raddrizzare la schiena e dire no ci sono
cose che non siamo in grado di accettare
ci sono cose che non possiamo ammettere
ci sono valori che non possiamo e non
vogliamo rimettere in discussione tutto
diventa discutibile alla fine
ed ecco che ricompaiono anche il
fascismo il nazismo che ricompaiono quei
movimenti che negli anni trenta ci hanno
portato al disastro sulle stesse
motivazioni
sulla stessa linea d'onda sullo stesso
tipo di pensiero replicano quella logica
di
missione di alterità e soprattutto di
nostra superiorità rispetto al resto del
mondo
purtroppo il resto del mondo oggi allo
sbando l'organismo che ha sempre avuto
la massima responsabilità nel gestire le
cose mondiali nel fermare le guerre
l'organismo che nel 2005 si è dato la
responsabilità di proteggere le vittime
civili dei conflitti dove gli stati non
sono più in grado di farlo oggi è
completamente paralizzato
non so se nel consiglio di sicurezza
delle nazioni unite giochino a burraco
oa qualche altro gioco ma certamente non
si intrattengono analizzando studiando e
cercando soluzioni ai problemi del mondo
ma si dividono in un giochino di potere
il potere di veto di qua di là se tu
proponi una cosa io la ostacolo prima di
dire qualcosa sulla siria il consiglio
di sicurezza ha impiegato più di quattro
anni la guerra era scoppiata la guerra
seminava già decine di migliaia di
vittime e loro parlavano d'altro e
quando nel 2015 finalmente hanno emesso
una risoluzione sulla siria era una
risoluzione che non diceva niente che
non propongono da niente che non
risolverà niente siamo nelle mani di una
classe politica che non riesce a
guardare al di là del proprio
ristrettissimo cortile di casa e quella
logica che sembrava dominante e
crescente negli anni 90 della necessità
di assumere una responsabilità a livello
globale è stata completamente
abbandonata
anzi mi permetto di dire quella marcia
inesorabile dei diritti umani quella
marcia inesorabile del progresso della
civiltà dell'eguaglianza del rispetto di
tutti che con tante difficoltà tanti
ostacoli e tante contraddizioni dalla
fine della seconda guerra mondiale fino
a pochi anni fa sembrava comunque
un'ondata che nessuno avrebbe potuto
arrestare
oggi si è fermata e sta cominciando a
tornare indietro
lo vediamo nelle politiche
antiterrorismo lo vediamo nelle
politiche dei tanti paesi che stanno
sistematicamente riducendo i diritti
umani per i loro cittadini e per i
cittadini di altri paesi
lo vediamo nel ritorno della pena di
morte quest'anno ci sono state
nell'ultimo anno ci sono state molte più
esecuzioni di quante ce ne siano state
nell'anno precedente
per la prima volta in decenni si torna
indietro anche su quello d'altronde il
mondo che stanno fuori il mondo che
questa politica è chiamata a governare
in qualche modo a guidare e un mondo che
spaventa è un mondo di miliardi di
persone che vivono in una specie di
alveare queste port au prince
vista dall'alto un alveare in cui
nascono spesso soffrono inevitabilmente
muoiono di solito moneta molto giovane e
in cui non riescono a trovare neanche un
barlume di luce che indichi loro il
futuro si vive si lotta per il presente
in un mondo sempre più diseguale
in un mondo dove la diseguaglianza sta
peggiorando sistematicamente da alcuni
decenni creando quella situazione che
abbiamo visto descritta nel precedente 8
persone che detengono la stessa
ricchezza di metà della popolazione
mondiale l'un per cento della
popolazione mondiale che detiene la
stessa ricchezza del rimanente 99 per
cento quale logica può sostenere la una
dis di ford è fornita di questo tipo una
distorsione così acuta e poi un mondo
che è scosso da un cambio climatico che
purtroppo tendiamo sempre tutti quanti a
vedere come un'ipotesi come una
possibilità del futuro
forse influenzati dalla fantascienza
pensiamo che magari fra 30 40 50 anni ci
sarà un'ondata di marea gigantesca che
seppellirà perfino l'everest
distruggendo tutto non è così
il cambio climatico c'è il cambio
climatico sta provocando danni
inenarrabili sta ridisegnando la
geografia antropica del nostro pianeta
il cambio climatico e provocato negli
ultimi 50 anni un aumento dei disastri
naturali del mille per cento si sono
moltiplicati per 11 volte i disastri
naturali di natura climatica colpiscono
centinaia di milioni di persone ogni
anno
ogni anno almeno 20 milioni di persone
vengono sfollate per sempre da un
disastro climatico e vanno ad alimentare
quell'enorme massa di persone che non
hanno altra possibilità di sopravvivenza
se non emigrare da qualche parte magari
dalla campagna verso la città magari dal
proprio paese in quello confinante
all'interno della stessa regione
o magari attirati dal vero pool factor
che attira tanti migranti in europa la
voglia di andare a vivere non posso dove
i diritti umani siano bene o male
rispettati dove ci sia un assistenza
sanitaria gratuita dove ci sia la
possibilità di lavorare di condurre una
vita dignitosa senza essere esposti alla
violenza al sopruso alla schiavitù come
le persone che partono da questi paesi
da paesi come questo la guerra terzo
grande fattore dinamico che sta
modificando la la natura del mondo dopo
un decennio in cui sembrava il primo
decennio degli anni 2000 in cui sembrava
che i conflitti dovessero bene o male
sedarsi ridursi
dopo le emergenze complesse degli anni
90 si sperava in un cambio di passo nel
oggi i conflitti sono in crescita ogni
anno muoiono 250 mila persone nei
conflitti la vendita incontrollata degli
armamenti fatta dagli stessi paesi
occidentali che hanno sottoscritto
trattati che li proibiscono di vendere
armi a paesi in guerra sta prosperando
in modo significativo si muove di
persona il presidente holland per andare
a vendere le armi all'arabia saudita per
bombardare lo yemen
così come il ministro della difesa
pinotti che è andato a rinegoziare la
vendita di bombe all'arabia saudita che
le usa contro la popolazione civile in
yemen che la usa per distruggere gli
ospedali che le usa per distruggere le
scuole per colpire civili innocenti
non abbiamo più nessuno scrupolo quella
serie di valori che sembrava fino agli
anni 90 che comunque l'occidente
riuscisse a mantenere solidi almeno
nelle sue politiche essenziali
oggi sono andati completamente a ramengo
e poi c'è la migrazione prodotto delle
dinamiche che vi ho appena descritto
ma anche fattori dinamico di per sé
quanto impatta la migrazione la
migrazione sta condizionando interamente
la nostra vita politica non si parla d
altro da anni e non si parla d altro
anche negli stati uniti anche negli
altri paesi europei
si cercano tutti i possibili
collegamenti i migranti portano malattie
i migranti sono terroristi i migranti ci
rubano il lavoro
nessuna di queste condizioni è
dimostrata scientificamente
realistica eppure sono gli argomenti
fondamentali del dibattito politico in
europa come in nord america e della
migrazione che li provo
quindi noi non impediamo alla gente di
fuggire perché non tentiamo neanche
minimamente di risolvere i problemi che
hanno a casa loro e quando la gente
costretta a fuggire e lì
aggiungiamo un muro dicendo voi da qui
non passate ecco quindi che la logica
dominante sembra essere non salviamo le
barche in mare è vietato portare cibo e
rifugiati i volontari che vanno i domani
ad assistere i rifugiati vengono
arrestati dalla polizia greca
se un cittadino da un passaggio europeo
da un passaggio rifugiato viene multato
per il reato di traffico di esseri umani
ieri fortunatamente è stato assolto
felix croft cittadino francese che ha
aiutato alcuni rifugiati a passare la
frontiera con la francia c'è ancora un
giudice a berlino si direbbe
c'è ancora qualcuno che comunque riesce
a difendere alcuni dei principi
fondamentali della nostra civiltà
ma se fosse per la politica tutta questa
gente andrebbe in galera come andrebbero
in galera quelli che salvano i naufraghi
come andrebbero in galera tutto sommato
tutti questi buonisti che meraviglioso
artificio dialettico questo del buonismo
no l'accusa da sbattere in faccia la
gente voglio dire dieci anni fa essere
chiamati i buonisti sarebbe stato un
complimento
dieci anni fa gli operatori delle
energie erano dei bravi ragazzi che
facevano delle cose meravigliose è tutta
la vita che mi sento dire ma che bel
lavoro che fai ma quanto è bello e
nobile quello che fai adesso sono
diventato più o meno un criminale agli
occhi di una buona metà della
cittadinanza cosa opponendo il mondo a
tutta questa grande catastrofe
umanitaria prodotta dal cambio climatico
dalle guerre dalla diseguaglianza
economica
questo numero 53 per cento
l'intero aiuto umanitario globale del
2016 che era peraltro inferiore di 4
miliardi a quello del 2015
quindi i soldi che gli stati danno in
aiuto umanitario per proteggere
popolazioni colpite ha coperto solamente
il 53 per cento dei bisogni nel 2016
vuol dire che metà delle persone esposte
a disastri naturali ea guerra non ha
ricevuto assistenza ed è interessante
vedere come le nazioni unite aderiscano
alla fine a questo spirito tant'è che
nell'appello presentato agli stati per
chiedere risorse umanitarie per il 2017
le nazioni unite dicono ci sono 128
milioni di persone in grave stato di
bisogno
noi vi chiediamo 22 miliardi quindi 2
miliardi in meno che nel 2016 per 92
milioni di persone in 33 paesi i 90 228
mi mancano 36 milioni di persone al
conto beh quelle se la caverà ma in
qualche modo da sole sono affari loro
considerate che se chiedo 22 milioni
probabilmente non riceverò 16 17 quindi
sta precipitando quell'unico meccanismo
che ancora ci permetteva di contenere in
parte la sofferenza di centinaia di
milioni di persone
e sempre meno riceveranno tant'è che ai
confini della siria nei campi di
rifugiati non si fanno più programmi
educativi perché non ci sono i soldi si
riducono le razioni alimentari perché
non ci sono i soldi si riducono i
servizi medici perché non ci sono i
soldi
e intanto di questi 22 miliardi 8
miliardi sono destinati alla siria certo
la siria è la crisi più importante del
momento non è necessariamente la
peggiore ma se 8 miliardi su 22 lidia ma
la siria di altri 32 paesi dovranno
arrangiarsi con quattro spiccioli per il
sudan per il sud sudan per la somalia
per
il mali per il ciad per la repubblica
centrafricana per il burundi paesi dove
sono in corso dei genocidi e poi ci
domandiamo perché la gente scappa
e poi diciamo ma aiutiamoli a casa loro
casa loro questa è la siria è questa
casa loro
aiutiamoli a casa loro
una siria in cui centinaia di migliaia
di persone esattamente 400 mila persone
vivendo in una condizione di assedio da
parte delle forze governative o
dell'opposizione non ricevono assistenza
umanitaria e quindi sono condannate a
morire di fame o di malattie o delle
conseguenze della violenza nei prossimi
mesi
questa è la fila per il pane
due anni fa al campo di yarmouk campo di
rifugiati palestinesi in siria ma questa
è la situazione in cui vive ormai meta
della popolazione siriana 500 mila morti
due milioni di feriti sei milioni di
sfollati interni 5 milioni di rifugiati
un'aspettativa di vita che è crollata di
15 anni tra il 2010 e il 2015 in siria
in siria dove solamente per comprare il
minimo di acqua da bere bisogna spendere
almeno un quarto del proprio reddito
questa è la siria ed è il paradigma di
quello che il mondo incapace di fare
oggi una serial a cui si può solamente
fuggire come da tanti altri paesi non
c'è alternativa che andarsene
salvo poi ritrovarsi abbandonati a se
stessi sono disperati senza assistenza
senza protezione magari nelle belle
strade asfaltate di un paese europeo
dove sei considerato comunque come una
faccia da respingere e non come un
essere umano dai
con senso di umanità e il consiglio di
sicurezza tace e lascia fare la politica
tace lascia fare anzi semmai cerca dei
mezzi per limitare ulteriormente
vorremmo che morissero tutti in mare
così non ci vengono a rompere le palle
nel nostro paese è questo che ci dicono
i politici oggi si fa di tutto per
impedire l'assistenza a queste persone
al punto di avere creato dei nuovi reati
che definire ai reati di solidarietà e
reati di umanità per impedire che questi
rifugiati vengano aiutati e inutile come
dice il nostro segretario generale di
amnesty international
bisogna prendere atto che ormai non
possiamo più affidare agli stati ai
governi la responsabilità di proteggere
i diritti umani non sono più pronti a
farlo dobbiamo riprenderci noi questa
responsabilità come cittadini come
persona questo vuol dire che non basta
più guardare scuotendo la testa
preoccupati quello che succede nel mondo
questo significa che dobbiamo
ricominciare a prendere l'iniziativa
direttamente e personalmente ciascuno di
noi per difendere i nostri diritti e
quelli di tutti perché siamo in presenza
di un fenomeno impressionante di
negazione cancellazione dei diritti
umani che tocca tutti i cittadini e poi
se ne sapete qualcosa di diritti umani
sapete che se io ridurre i diritti umani
in un paese prima o poi quell'effetto si
riproduce anche in altri paesi che se si
abbassa lo standard da qualche parte
prima o poi lo standard si abbasserà
dappertutto guardate già come conviviamo
ormai rassegnati con le politiche anti
terrorismo che pure limitano così
grandemente
la nostra libertà di movimento il nostro
diritto a vivere serenamente la nostra
vita
vediamo come sempre più la politica e
penso alle parole di donald trump
le parole di contro le donne contro i
disabili contro gli eroi di guerra che
avevano il difetto magari di praticare
una religione diversa da quella che lui
ammesso che abbia un'idea di che cosa
sia la religione considera la religione
dominante del suo paese e questi
discorsi li sentiamo fare dalla lega al
phone nazional ai seguaci della break
set e in gran bretagna al leader
ungheresi ai leader polacchi a
personaggi di primo piano della politica
nord europea
non stiamo parlando solamente del
presidente di perth e nelle filippine
che ha pensato bene che sterminare i
drogati si è un modo per fermare il
traffico di droga nel suo paese abbiamo
centinaia di politici oggi nel mondo che
stanno praticando e predicando odio
violenza sopruso che negazione dei
diritti quindi dobbiamo riprendere noi
l'iniziativa dobbiamo attivarci dobbiamo
fare qualcosa è una chiamata alle armi
si è una chiamata alle armi per tutti
noi soprattutto per voi mi permetto di
dire
combatterò in nei prossimi 20 o 30 anni
ma sono abbastanza vecchio chi come voi
ha di fronte una prospettiva di una vita
ancora molto lunga e particolarmente
importante che si impegni da oggi nel
proprio quotidiano nella propria
comunità nel proprio posto di lavoro
nella propria vita
abbiamo tanti modi per resistere a
questo cambiamento
innanzitutto abbiamo le leggi le leggi
sui diritti umani sono dannatamente
difficili da cambiare di solito
richiedono grandi maggioranze di solito
ogni tentativo di cambiamento incontro
una forte opposizione da chi ha a cuore
diritti umani e non sono operazioni
politiche semplici quelli di cancellare
i diritti
abbiamo visto come il muslim band di
donald trump sia stato ostacolato dalla
parola di pochi giudici che negli stati
uniti hanno semplicemente sancito
l'illegittimità del provvedimento e la
cosa si è fermata non si fermerà per
sempre
riuscirà a cambiare le leggi trump
riuscirà a ottenere probabilmente una
sentenza della corte suprema degli stati
uniti a favore del suo bando non di meno
nondimeno si guadagna tempo si creano
spazi si aprono possibilità e poi una
società civile attiva è sempre stata la
risposta principale quando gli stati non
hanno fatto il loro dovere
io vorrei ricordare perché ho una vita
abbastanza lunga e un militato per
decenni nel campo umanitario ma voglio
dire dalla lotta contro l'apartheid alla
lotta contro le mine antipersona alla
lotta per il traffico per un controllo
del traffico delle armi alla
cancellazione del debito per i paesi più
poveri alla creazione della corte penale
internazionale queste sono tutte
vittoria che negli ultimi 30 anni la
società civile ha ottenuto a dispetto
della politica una società civile attiva
e dinamica è una forza irresistibile
e poi diciamolo e con questo concludo se
alla fin fine i nostri avversari quelli
che predicano odio quelli che predicano
divisione quelli che ci chiamano
buonisti ci considerano una
perché discorso che noi saremmo un'elite
non un élite economica evidentemente
frugata nelle vostre tasche ditemi se
sbaglio ma certamente un élite culturale
certamente siamo persone che studiano
che leggono che si informano che
approfondiscono siamo persone che prima
di tranciare il giudizio riflettono
siamo persone che sanno ascoltare gli
altri siamo persone tolleranti nei
confronti delle idee diverse dalle
nostre
siamo persone che contano su una rete di
relazioni internazionali molto forte e
che sono capaci di contribuire alla
mobilitazione al carattere globale se
necessario siamo persone che ragionano
che scrivono che pensano che sanno
produrre idee di qualità quelle che
abbiamo visto scorrere in questa
giornata in questa sala una dietro
l'altra tutte meravigliose tutti
eccezionali tutte in grado di portare
dei grandi cambiamenti
noi sì che siamo un'elite è vero siamo
un'elite perché pensiamo perché
rispettiamo gli altri perché crediamo
nei diritti perché abbiamo dei valori
perché vogliamo il bene comune e allora
se siamo nel it usiamo i nostri
strumenti non lasciamo che siano i bruti
a prendere la guida del dibattito
politico
riportiamo c noi al centro del dibattito
armiamoci lo chiamo e vinciamo un'altra
volta la nostra battaglia per i diritti
come abbiamo fatto 70 anni fa grazie
[Applauso]